it took us a little while to write the
script we don't really write pretty
quickly we know we're going to improvise
on set so we don't fuss over our
dialogue the writing process took over a
year um
with script notes and things like that
not all of which were bad it wasn't that
thing we're like oh they're dumb they're
making stuff we're right like they had
some good ideas but it's a it's an
intellectual talked about process the
discussion
is really dangerous because it starts to
kill the art when you talk about it jay
and i don't talk about it we move fast
and when we're shooting the movie we're
normally three to four months away from
the moment we birthed the idea so we're
still in the dating phase with the movie
where we're in love with it and want to
be with it when you make a studio movie
you have talked it and talked it to
death and you fall out of love with it
so the first thing that happened was we
called fox searchlight after they said
we love the script we're ready to go we
looked at and we said
we don't love it anymore we're not going
to make the movie
um and it wasn't like a rebellious thing
no it was just a really dumb thing that
we did yeah uh
we did not know that at the time yeah
but we just didn't feel it we were like
this is different so we basically
rewrote it in 20 days went back and went
back and they were like okay i guess so
i mean what we kind of realized after is
that we were making a
six and a half million dollar movie with
john c reilly and jonah hill and marissa
tomei and catherine keener and they were
going to make the movie with us
regardless yeah we didn't realize that
once you have your movie cast they kind
of lets you do what you want that was a
lucky we made a major power play i mean
and it wasn't like on accident they
didn't like the script but the script
was definitely
more us it was darker and weirder
and it was it had dark relationship
moments like this one that we just saw
and the original script was definitely
more
set copy set pc
um
so the actors went along with it they
were happy they loved it they loved it
and they
felt what we were doing they knew that
we were making it more real so you so
you at what point you would cast it
after you finished your first version
and then yeah we'd cast it um
we'd cast it off of the let's see i
think we cast jonah off of the pitch
maybe i don't know if john even read the
script oh no he read a first draft yeah
they came on mostly in the early stages
of the draft there was some drifting
from that vision and then we kind of
were able to get it back